foreign
[Music]
I run the r4ds online learning community
our community operates primarily through
a slack team and we invite our Learners
at all skill levels to join us at
r4ds.io join
among other things we host book clubs
for our related books whenever we start
a new cohort for one of the book clubs
we need to find a time that works for as
many of the people interested in reading
the book as we can
we used to use a generic free online app
for everyone to sign up
everyone would type in their name choose
their available times and days and then
set a password in case they wanted to
edit their selections
sometimes people would sign up twice not
remembering that John who was signed up
already was them
at least one time someone had a typo in
their name so when they came back to
change their available hours it counted
as a new person
and of course sometimes we legitimately
had multiple people with the same name
signing up so I didn't have any way to
sort out who was who and how many
duplicates we had
and even when everything went smoothly I
didn't have an easy way to connect the
information in that app to their slack
user so I couldn't contact people
directly to let them know that a cohort
was being created at a time they'd
chosen so I figured we already all have
logins to the r4ds slack what if we made
our own app in shiny and then connected
that to the slack API
then the app could talk to our slack and
connect each user to their Identity On
r4ds
I posted the idea on our slack and one
of our users Priyanka gognija
volunteered to make the initial app
minus the login and then I focused on
the login part
I'd already done some work with Yani CD
on his slack teams package which allows
you to talk to slack through r
you can find that and Yanni's whole
slack verse family of packages on GitHub
at Yanni CD slack teams
my goal was to take what I did there
with interactive slack authorization
uh make it work in shiny and then wrap
that up into an easy to use package
so this is what that looks like if you
aren't already logged in it asks you to
log in using Slack from that initial
screen you're taken to Slack's
permission screen to connect to your
slack account and then it returns you to
the shiny app here we just use the
connection to identify the user but I
have another app where we use it to make
sure the user has permission to see
certain messages and I'm working on one
that will help users ask better
questions and then post those questions
as them
so it works now let's see how I did on
the easy to use part of the goal you can
install this from GitHub at r4ds shiny
Slack
this is one of the ways we can launch a
normal shiny app we Define a UI Define a
server function and wrap them in Chinese
shinyapp function
now we'll use shiny slack to add a slack
login to that app we replace shiny's
shinyat with shiny slacks shiny slack
app we also need to give it the code
that identifies our slack team and
that's it
well kinda so you probably want to
deploy your app to something like
shinyapps.io not just run the app
locally and to do that you'll need your
own slack app that has permission to
send people to apps hosted on your
shinyapps account
when I first started working on this
setting up the slack side of things was
really complicated I was kind of
dreading explaining this part I mean I
just did that thing showing you how easy
it is to set up the shiny side of this
and this part was going to ruin that
uh but then something magical happened
slack added an option to create a slack
app from something called a manifest
so I added a function over in slack
teams create custom app to make that
easy there's a vignette explaining it
but basically you call create custom app
with a couple arguments and copy paste
the result into slacks app creation form
and with that you can wrap your shiny
app with shiny slack and integrate it
with your select team
if you'd like to learn more stop by the
r4ds slack at r4ds.io join we're putting
together a new club where we walk
through side projects like this so you
can learn all about how this works under
the hood over there
foreign
[Music]